this is unit become er bringing you the
highlights from the world rapid
championship magnus carlsen got four
points out of five today it is a decent
score
he is half a point behind the the
leaders but it's he hasn't played the
top dogs just yet so it will be
interesting to see what he can bring on
the final day this is from round 10 when
he played against the tajiki Grandmaster
Aminata
and he actually made a brilliant
strategic masterpiece his Bishop on b6
you could argue that this Bishop is not
doing a great job because it's kind of
it's not helping the white pieces on the
rest of the board however it is doing a
great job of protecting the d8 square
and making sure that none of the black
pieces on the queenside can really move
and and look at this Bishop look at this
Queen
look at this rook these pieces are
terrible they're not doing anything and
Magnus was able to exploit that he
played here in Knight takes d4 takes
back and f4 he found the correct moment
to expand his territory on the board and
after Knight II 6 e 5 you can see that
the white pants are dominating and also
notice how the bishop points up towards
blacks King a very good plan he managed
to execute was that he could bring his
knight from g3 up to e4 and further on
to d6 look at the difference in the in
their in their pieces blacks pieces are
durable and the bishop and the knight is
is just tying black down completely
it drove Aminata to desperation trying
to sacrifice a night to get the the
pieces loose from White's grip but after
Queen f2 takes takes takes yes you have
three pawns for a piece but the bishop
decides the game with the attack on the
black queen and when the Queen moves the
rook is going being a so lost and that
was just the finish to what was a a good
strategic game from Magnus